historic votes in the House of
Representatives mean the shadow of
impeachment is now hanging over the
trump presidency forever this morning as
we just pointed out these are the
headlines around the country lawmakers
approved two articles of impeachment
abuse of power and obstruction of
Congress on a pair of party line boats
last night mr. Trump becomes the third
president in US history after Andrew
Johnson and Bill Clinton to face a trial
now in the Senate the president was
surrounded by thousands of his
supporters in Battle Creek Michigan when
the results of the votes were announced
it doesn't really feel like we're being
impeached the country is doing better
than ever before we did nothing wrong at
the heart of his impeachment is an
allegation the president used the power
of his office to pressure a foreign
government to investigate a political
opponent the public can say the charges
are phony while Democrats insisted they
had to hold the president to account
December 18th a great day to the
Constitution of the United States a sad
one for America that the president's
reckless activities necessitated us are
having to introduce articles of
impeachment this morning we'll discuss
impeachment with Senate Democratic
leader Chuck Schumer and the president's
spokeswoman Stephane Grisham first we go
to Nancy Cordes who was on Capitol Hill
for last night's historic debate Nancy
where do we go from here
well what would typically happen Anthony
is that this would all move over to the
Senate for a speedy trial but it appears
that House Democrats are delaying the
naming of impeachment managers House
speaker Pelosi says she's concerned that
the Senate trial won't be a fair one the
yeas are 229 the nays are 198 present is
one Article two is adopted speaker
Pelosi presided over the historic votes
and then put the brakes on the next step
this is
serious matter even though the majority
leader in the United States Senate says
it's okay for the foreman of the jury to
become cahoots with the lawyers of the
accused Democrats are worried that the
republican-led Senate which will now
determine the president's fate will
refuse to call witnesses in the trial to
come
last night's votes broke as expected
almost totally along party lines with
all but four House Democrats voting for
both articles of impeachment today we
take a stand against corruption and
abuses of power about 250 House members
spoke during a full day of debate
questioning the other side's motives and
its facts Democrats did not choose this
impeachment this majority say be damned
with anything else we're going to
impeach and do whatever we want to do
why because we want an election I
guarantee you one day you'll be back in
the minority and it ain't gonna be that
fun what they can't say is this
president has upheld his oath of office
no they can't say that all they can say
is we don't like the process here's
President today he'll be President
tomorrow and he will be President
when this impeachment is over speaker
Pelosi called it a solemn moment in the
nation's history even urging her members
not to clap after the final votes
article 1 is adopted
okay in her final words of the day she
invoked the memory of the late
Democratic congressman Elijah Cummings
he also said somewhat presciently
when we were dancing with the angels the
question will be what did you do to make
sure we kept our democracy intact we did
all we could elijah because the two
articles of impeachment the president is
impeached Senate Leader Mitch McConnell
says that he is going to speak on the
Senate floor about impeachment this
morning and that he is going to meet
with his Democratic counterpart Chuck
Schumer by the end of the week but what
is clear here this morning tony is that
while one battle over the vote in the
house has ended the next battle has
already begun Nancy thank you very much